pretty song I've never heard before the
new one
are you hungry we've got some rather I
don't want to say your food you're not
stealing we're offering come on it's
going to be a cold night
you head in South King Sunday
poor girl that's a bad deal it depends
on your taste I guess if you like your
streets covered in [ __ ] and pig's blood
it's the town for you for my life only
to see the red sheep accepted Baelor the
dragon pit then when I finally make it
they wouldn't let move in a mile the red
keep it set to bay lows blown to hell
and the dragon pit sat down ruin people
who lived there I'd skin you alive if
they can make two poppers off your hide
worst place in the world what are you
doing in the Riverland there's been some
trouble to phrase up at the twins
so we part the army that's been sent to
keep the peace here you go guess first I
know I couldn't either have enough my
mother always told me to be kind to
strangers strangers to be kind to you
very long way from home I'm sure you've
had some adventures oh yeah endless
adventures they'll be singing about us
for a thousand years the truth is when
we left home we can wait to get away but
now we've been gone a while we can't
like to get home I just think about my
dad out there on his boat all alone
looks down here we do my wife says that
our first baby well go who knows
you think soldiers get Ravens with news
from home I hope it's a girl why does
take care of their Papa's when the pup
was grow up always just go off the fight
and someone else's wolves are you old
enough to drink
it's blackberry wine I made it myself 20
good wives a nice girl on our own
heading to King's Landing I'm going to
kill the Queen
[Laughter]
you